tu es vraiment romantique ouais
je pense alors
pourquoi dis-tu que
euh
je ne sais pas je pense juste que je le suis je veux dire je
pense
surtout quand j'étais tu sais euh
15 à 20 et toi tu penses que la vie
va être comme la  les films que vous connaissez
et tout ce genre de choses que je comprends je
suis romantique
comme une fin heureuse
mais rêviez-vous du parfait
la carrière parfaite l'homme parfait la
configuration parfaite
je ne sais pas peut-être que j'étais je veux dire je ne
me souviens pas vraiment  maintenant spécifiquement ce que je
pensais à l'époque mais euh
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais vraiment rêvé que ce qui
arriverait avec ma carrière arriverait
parce que ça se passait c'était
parfait comme ça se passait
mais je ne savais pas où ça allait
en fin de compte, vous savez que j'étais un peu ouvert à
tout,
je veux dire, je pensais que ma carrière se
déroulait très bien avant la Grèce, mais je
n'ai réalisé à quel point
elle était plus grande qu'après le film,
car
dans tous les pays, je veux dire, je suis allé à
Paris pour
euh
juste pour faire du shopping et les gens connaissaient mon
visage dans la rue et je suis allé à
amsterdam et tu ne parlais pas anglais
mais ils savaient mon ils ont dit oh ouais s'il vous plaît
je ne peux pas m'échapper mais c'est génial
c'est fantastique que le film ait
fait ça  eh bien je suis ravi mais tu
sais
effrayant c'est effrayant parfois j'ai eu
peur en étant assailli euh je
pense que le plus effrayant était la
première de graisse à londres avec john travolta nous
étions dans une limousine c'était comme les
beatles  vraiment parce qu'ils ont sauté sur le toit
de la voiture
en criant et en se couchant dessus et en frappant
sur les vitres et en frappant sur le toit
c'était vraiment très effrayant je
pensais qu'ils allaient passer par
le toit
et nous ne pouvions pas sortir et
rendez-vous avec John  Lou sortait de
la voiture et ils ont presque déchiré tous leurs
vêtements je veux dire que c'était vraiment
effrayant et nous avons réussi à entrer
avec environ
cinq policiers autour de nous comme ça mais
nous sommes tous les deux très secoués nous n'y sommes pas allés
dans le film,
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
John n'était pas encore une grande star de cinéma parce que
les gens sataniques n'étaient même pas sortis, mais
je savais qu'il serait une grande star,
vous savez, je ne suis pas une actrice, alors pour  parle
donc j'étais nerveux à ce sujet il était
formidable très encourageant et soutenant
ce qu'il était tout au long du
film
quel genre de chansons préfériez-vous vraiment
à l'époque j'ai toujours aimé les ballades je
pense que les ballades sont mes
coyotes comme en dehors du  désert tu
sais ici ils vont
euh
je pense que les bellas ont toujours été ma
chose préférée
du bon ciel
j'ai très protégé mes chiens comme vous pouvez l'entendre
euh
pourquoi je ne sais pas parce que oui je
pense que
je pense que je suis un romantique je  je suis un romantique
et les ballades sont
généralement tristes et sentimentales et et
j'aime les voir tu te tais je te demande
lucy peut peindre
est ce jackson ouais mon chien
comment l'as-tu eu
il m'a été donné par un fan
quand j'étais dedans  une tournée il y a environ cinq ans,
j'étais dans un endroit appelé jackson dans
le mississippi
et un fan m'a rassemblé et m'a dit qu'il
savait que mon chien préféré était un
setter irlandais et qu'il avait une portée et
qu'il aimerait que j'ai le choix  de la
portée
et j'ai résisté et résisté et puis j'étais
quand il a amené le chiot je pense que
j'étais à un spectacle et je suis revenu et il
était enfermé dans la salle de bain en train de faire cette
petite chose
avec un sentier derrière lui bien sûr
et il  était à moi à partir de cette minute oh non je
ne pouvais pas le laisser partir il est si mignon je t'aime je t'aime
honnêtement j'ai acquis des chiens je
pense que les gens non j'ai je suis un
toucher doux alors ils m'appellent quand
ils ont  j'ai un chien errant ou un chien qui a besoin
d'une maison ou quelque chose alors
avez-vous toujours eu des animaux autour de vous non je pense que c'est pourquoi j'ai une telle
passion pour eux quand j'étais petite
fille
je n'avais pas le droit d'avoir des animaux dans lesquels je vivais
les terrains universitaires en Australie
et donc j'avais l'habitude de ramener des chiens errants à la maison, ce qui
était mon excuse car vous savez au moins je
pouvais les avoir temporairement
et je ramenais toujours à la maison, vous savez,
des chiens perdus et des chatons errants et des choses,
puis ma mère et moi avons vécu dans  un
appartement et je ne pouvais pas avoir de chiens alors
j'ai décidé que c'était mon objectif principal d'
avoir une maison pour que je puisse avoir
des animaux et je pense que j'ai rattrapé ces
années, ce n'est pas ton seul objectif
c'était '  t tu
non mais c'était l'un d'eux
donc tu es né en angleterre puis tu es allé
en australie à melbourne je suis né en
ouais je suis né en angleterre et je suis allé ma
famille a migré en australie quand j'avais
cinq ans mon père s'est vu offrir un poste  dans
une université là-bas, donc j'étais une petite
fille quand j'ai quitté l'angleterre, donc l'australie
se sent vraiment comme chez moi parce que j'ai grandi
là-bas et
je n'ai pas vraiment d'accent anglais
ou quoi que ce soit qu'il
enseignait il était professeur
d'allemand pensez-vous  parler en allemand non
parce que
ma mère est allemande et quand mes parents
voulaient parler en privé ils
parlaient en allemand donc je ne comprenais pas alors
ils m'apprenaient
[la musique]
tu te souviens quand tu as commencé à chanter
pour la première fois 14.
j'avais une petite amie à l'école qui avait l'habitude de
jouer avec le chant et nous avons rencontré deux autres
filles et nous avions l'habitude d'aller dans ces
clubs de jazz euh je me souviens de la première fois que
nous avons fait ça on nous a jeté des sous
nous étions tellement abominables
mon frère  -law avait un salon de café
et j'avais l'habitude d'y aller et ils avaient un
chanteur folk sur scène et je
chantais avec lui d'où j'étais
assis
jusqu'au jour où il m'a invité sur scène
avec lui et je suis allé
et  puis et a fait une chanson avec lui et
puis il a dit pourquoi ne viendrais-tu pas le
week-end et chanter avec moi
c'est vraiment comme ça que ça a commencé
[Musique]
jackson
tu veux jouer pour quelque chose pour moi
[Musique]
les choses qui
t'attiraient  la musique classique ou
n'importe quelle
musique classique
j'aime ça maintenant mais pendant de nombreuses années je
ne l'aimais pas du tout parce que mes parents ont
divorcé quand j'avais environ 10 ans
et mon père écoutait
tout le temps de la musique classique et j'ai
associé d'une manière ou d'une autre le classique à  lui
et quand je l'ai entendu et qu'il n'était pas là,
cela me rendait très triste, alors pendant des années
et des années, je ne l'écoutais pas maintenant,
j'ai réalisé que
vous savez ce qui m'a fait ressentir
cela et j'apprécie  c'est maintenant qu'on m'a parlé
de ce
concours de talents qui était à la télévision
qui allait être sur l'équivalent
d'un kiosque à musique américain ici
et à mon grand étonnement j'ai tout gagné
et le prix était un voyage en
angleterre
et un peu de prix  de l'argent alors j'avais
15 ans j'avais la première chose que j'ai faite j'ai gagné j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance c'est un conte de fées c'est le
voyage que j'avais gagné au concours de cette ville
le billet n'était valable qu'un an alors
ma mère a dit si nous '  je vais nous devons y
aller maintenant je ne voulais vraiment pas aller en
angleterre je ne voulais pas partir j'étais
très heureux en australie et je croyais
que l'australie était tout ce qu'il y avait
je suis resté en angleterre et
j'ai rejoint un groupe
quel genre de bien  terrible groupe
trois gars et moi-même et euh
il semblait que ça allait être
formidable parce que don kirschner qui a
assemblé les singes était
un partenaire un producteur
et harry saltzman qui a fait tous les
films de james bond était l'autre partenaire
maintenant vous le penseriez  ne pouvait pas manquer ne
vous
tromperiez pas c'était vraiment mauvais je veux dire mauvais plus tard de
quelle façon tout simplement
terrible ils pensaient que nous allions
être les
singes des années 70 vous savez et nous
allons notre premier film
était euh
comment puis-je expliquer
un  espace
musical
dans lequel nous étions ils ont
choisi vous savez les quatre types qu'ils
pensaient être parfaits j'étais comme le
tout américain ou tout anglais ou tout ce que
vous vouliez fille australienne nous avions une
amérique un très beau
gars de type cowboy du midwest américain
un philly noir  un batteur de Philadelphie qui
était vraiment cool et vraiment mignon et un
personnage anglais de tommy steele cockney
nous sommes tous les quatre et nous nous sommes
réunis nous ne nous sommes jamais rencontrés auparavant et nous avons
dit de répéter vous savez ce qu'on fait
maintenant
et euh
fait ce film
et le scénario  était terrible et
tout était terrible et ils ont mis
beaucoup d'argent derrière et il a ouvert et
fermé environ une semaine
après un an de
l'histoire typique était ils nous ont téléphoné
et nous ont dit de venir à new york alors et vous
savez qu'ils sont des foires de première classe  et ils
m'ont donné ma sœur pourrait venir avec moi
chaperon Je suis arrivé à new york et j'ai dirigé
le bureau et j'ai dit que nous étions ici et ils ont dit
qu'est-ce que tu fais ici
et j'ai dit eh bien tu m'as dit de venir et j'ai
dit oh non c'était '  t pendant deux semaines alors
ils nous ont envoyés en vacances c'était ce genre
de chose pendant un an
j'ai deux demi-coyotes c'est un chien sauvage
par ici
qui ont été trouvés au bord de la route
ils étaient morts de faim et très
effrayés et la fille  qui s'occupe de
mes animaux les a amenés et a dit que nous
les gardions juste jusqu'à ce que je puisse trouver une maison et
c'était il y a trois ans, ils sont toujours
là d'
accord ça suffit de ce bruit
êtes-vous prêt hein
ouais
c'est assez
stupide
salut zoggy comment tu vas venir  sur
[Applaudissements]
donc quand tu ne fais pas une chanson
immédiatement tu t'arrêtes
ouais la plupart des chansons que j'ai écrites
j'ai écrites
en une demi-heure boum se terminent et à moins que je
ne fasse ça je reviens vraiment en arrière et je les finis
si  je ne me sens pas inspiré, ce qui
est paresseux, je veux dire si vous êtes un vrai
auteur-compositeur, vous vous asseyez et vous
le finissez même si ce n'est pas bon, vous le finissez
et le révisez, mais comme ce n'est pas mon
pain et mon beurre, c'est juste une sorte de
passe-temps que je ne fais pas le père
noël c'est un fantasme c'est un
fantasme musical avec beaucoup de danse
et de très bonne musique je suis vraiment ravi
de la musique euh c'est un je joue une muse
laquelle pour ceux d'entre vous j'ai joué
une chanson et une danse ivre  ou quelque chose que je ne
savais pas ce qu'était une muse quand j'ai
commencé à faire le script et que j'ai
lu rapidement de la musique dessus,
alors de toute façon je
descends du paradis ou peu importe comment vous
voulez l'appeler de temps en temps ouais
pour aider ce jeune homme  réaliser son rêve
et il y a aussi
un homme plus âgé qui a été joué par Gene
Kelly qui me connaissait quand il était jeune
ne réalise pas que je suis la même fille que
tu ne m'as toujours pas dit vraiment comment
tu voyais l'avenir toi  m'a dit au niveau du travail d'
accord pour moi pour moi je suppose que comme j'entre
dans la trentaine je suis dans la trentaine
je commence à penser plus à une
famille que je ne le faisais quand j'avais la vingtaine
et c'était le plus éloigné  chose qui me vient à
l'esprit vraiment parce que
j'appréciais tellement ma carrière que
je pense que ce serait bien à un moment donné
je n'ai pas de limite de temps mais je
commence
à penser que
j'ai tellement j'aimerais le partager avec
tu sais est-ce
que
tu as déjà bougé
quelqu'un que tu aimes, je veux
dire, es-tu inquiet qu'il t'aime
parce que tu es célèbre ou
bien sûr il y a toujours cette chose que tu
sais, c'est qu'il est emporté par le fait que
euh que je sois célèbre ou quoi que ce soit ou est-ce
qu'il m'aime pour moi ou  est-il après
quelque chose
mais vous
devez utiliser votre instinct et espérer cela
et leur faire confiance et espérer que vous avez
raison
je pense que généralement les gens se montrent
pour ce qu'ils sont d'une manière ou d'une autre
et j'espère qu'il n'est pas trop tard d'ici là
alors comment imaginez-vous que votre futur
mari
était
gentil et doux et attentionné
c'est tout je suppose que vous tombez amoureux des
gens ils ne sont pas toujours exactement ce que
vous cherchez
juste les aimer est la partie la plus importante
[Musique]
vous